Could fermented beef, organic beef sticks be the cause of my mold or high mycotoxins?
That's a really good question.
I don't know if
beef sticks or
like
beef jerky
Contains the type of mold that produces mycotoxins. I mean it can't get moldy any food could get moldy
But we're not what we're talking about the type of mold that produces mycotoxins
I don't we're not really talking about the mold that grows on bread
I don't think we're talking about if your beef sticks were moldy
Now it is true that some beef sticks
or
Sausages things like that could contain grains that could have had mold in them therefore could contain mycotoxins
That's a possibility, but I don't think any of the molds that produce mycotoxin could be run
I should investigate that for you, but I don't think so
You'll see your mycotoxin report
that
In the mycotoxin report, you'll see where those molds come from. So let's say if it's aspergillus mold where it can come from off top my head
I think aspergillus can
Grow in different grains and corn and wheat and different things. I don't think any of them are listed that they grow in
Meat products, but it could be grown. You can look on that mycotoxin report and see
But to answer this, I don't take so